okay people a people's last time
actually pretty useful huh haha thank
you
I'm a winner hey guys today is my turn
to flog the camera I really really want
to show you my room so my mom bought me
this couch it has blue and black right
here and my mom also got me a sheet so I
won't hurt my butt a bear that Joe gave
me a long time ago I call them Teddy and
I have my love bed right here it's
really cool right here I have my Legos
and right here I put bad guys here's a
DeLorean that my favorite Joe and JK and
I'm spot for me and up here I have this
is where I sleep and have a number sheet
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten and here is my tablet which I
always use to go sleep and also my mom
bought me light these lights like go
sleep and not be in the dark
cuz I'm afraid of the dark and right
here is my EVD TV here's when I went to
Zootopia or a lot here's my wallet
here's a note from my teacher is a I
forgot was it called so that's all my
room guys let's see what my mom and
Casey are doing and and and then diesel
ok did you show everybody your room yes
oh are you like vlogging yeah you're
like walking it's cool
can we go show them the garlic blurt
yeah
so now ready though just go check out
the garlic plant scope easy
nothing is proud of yet mommy never eat
is almost smothered a good a plan
something for you
of course we do you want to play oh I
know I know what tomatoes are gonna do
yeah sorry no planting for mother you're
such a sweet boy
well how did I get so lucky my sweetie
pie
all right sir all on our way to Target
to gather the supplies for my Mother's
Day present luckily we wanted to plant
tomatoes favorite Tomatoes is so fruit
that you be eating big stuff
oh you're smart that's true you should
call it a fruit - that's actually really
smart I grew up thinking our tomato as a
vegetable like a higher life until I was
a teenager then someone told me you know
what actually it's a fruit cuz SC
blinkers wrong one
u-turn be me back up end up blinkers on
you been putting the village oh you
remembers from the left from last week
hey you're strong you ready for some
Tomatoes okay let's go home but I don't
know why he's singing bet right after a
quick Google search
now we gather the supplies that we think
we need okay now my favorite boy is
gonna plant me a tomato plant
so is this favorite boy doodle for
Mother's Day okay okay all right thank
you wash love none yes I'll try to go
back uh like a belly we should move the
garlic plant over there and then we can
put the tomato in here so there's more
space for it to grow cause it's pretty
tall
oh there we go
you want to pour it in but here's good
and then we could put it in the tomato
plant so one it says partially fill the
container with our potting mix - what
does it say remove the plate from its
existing existing container look at that
big boy early girl 50 days oh you're
smart oh that's easy
Junius Tara let me help you up good job
why oh oh the tomato is losing its
foundation
yeah be really careful with that okay
your your fingers should never go in
between those those metal parts okay
I'm lucky to have such an awesome son I
feel so blessed I feel like I'm doing a
good job yeah there we go
loosen up all the edges all the way down
you
alright what's next Isaac we're gonna
meet dig a hole to make room for the
roots of the tomato plant you see in
Batman resonant and in it then oh no
spider-man
nananananana I hope you want to help me
yeah
moment of truth guys don't kill the
plant I'm scared let's see what's ahead
hmm I'm just trying pull the putt now
for Lou good job
perfect this is awesome and move the
putt out close the part out guys
Isaac I think we're doing it good job
guys teamwork all right you want to help
me spread it three answers food oh okay
it definitely does not stand on its own
is it heavy yep you got it coming out
your way good job sweetie pie he's
helped with the weight
Oh
chili zyk hi baby
okay see you left Casey hanging
equals equals mass tomato herb and herb
it's her baby to silent
all right big reason why we got all the
food was the last step change yep you
know what the cage does Isaac keeps the
French for that phone yeah
you
alright guys that was it that was
planting the Mother's Day gift for me oh
thank you sweetie thank you for enjoying
the video I have a nice day
hi that's it sign off the toy bye guys I
you're only on one leg